so let's talk about the most recent
Choice made by Vladimir Putin
the choice to invade Ukraine or to
escalate the invasion of Ukraine on
February 24th 2022.
now we're a few months removed
from that decision initial decision why
do you think he did it what are the
errors
in understanding the situation in
calculating the outcomes and
um everything else about this decision
in your view
yeah Lex when you don't when a war
doesn't go well it looks like lunacy to
have launched it in the first place does
it ever go well
war never goes according to plan
all war is based upon miscalculation but
not everybody is punished for their
miscalculation
all aggressive War we're talking about
not defensive War
is based upon miscalculation
but you can adjust you can recalibrate
you know when when you're driving down
the road and that very annoying voice is
telling you in a thousand
uh feet make a right yeah and you fail
to make a right it recalibrates right
yeah it tells you okay now you know go
uh turn around or U-turn or make a left
or it doesn't say you're an idiot and
turn around and make a U-turn but it
does recalibrate
so you can miscalculate and the problem
is not the miscalculation usually it's
the failure to do that adjustment right
people I know who are hedge fund Traders
they I asked them you know what's your
favorite trade and the line from them
all and this is a cliche is my favorite
trade is when I made a mistake
but I got out early
before all the Carnage so their favorite
trade is not when they made some
brilliant choice but it's when they
miscalculated but they reduced the
consequences of their miscalculation by
recalibrating quickly right so let's
talk about the calculation and
miscalculation of February
let's imagine Lex that you've been
getting away with murder
I don't mean murder in a figurative
sense I mean you've been murdering
people
you've been murdering them domestically
and you've been murdering them all
across Europe and you've been murdering
them not just with for example
a car accident a stage car accident or
using a handgun
you use novichok
or you use some other internationally
outlawed chemical weapon
and let's imagine that you did it and
nothing happened to you
it wasn't like you were removed from
power it wasn't like you paid a personal
price sure maybe there was some
sanctions on your economy but you didn't
pay the price of those sanctions little
people paid the price of those sanctions
other people in your country paid the
price let's imagine not only were you
murdering people literally
but you decided
to
entice the idiotic ruler of Georgia
into a provocation that you could then
invade the country
and you invaded the country and you bid
off these territories of kazia and South
assessia and what price did you pay for
that
and then you decided you know I think
I'll now invade Crimea and forcibly
Annex Crimea and I'll instigate an
Insurrection in the donbass in eastern
Ukraine in Lujan let's imagine you did
all that and then you had to stick out
your wrist so that you know
it could be slapped a couple of times
and you said you know I can pretty much
do what I want
they're putting a sanction here and
there and they're doing this and they're
doing that and and you know what they're
more energy dependent on me than before
I get better money laundering and
reputation Services than anybody has
maybe it's the Middle East and the
Chinese would disagree with you that
that you have better than them but yours
are pretty good and the Panama papers
get released revealing all of your
offshoring and your corruption and and
what hap nothing happens Lex so the
first and most important consideration
here is in your own mind
you've been getting away with murder
literally as well as figuratively and
you think you know I probably can do
something again and get away with it
and so the failure to respond at scale
in fact the indulgences the further
dependencies that are introduced the
illusion that trade is the mechanism to
manage authoritarian regimes you know
that great a German cliche
Avondale Handel right change through
trade or transformation through trade
one of Angela merkel's favorite
Expressions right you're you're gonna
get the other side
to be better
rather than confront them
in a cold war fashion where you stand up
to their aggressions and you punish them
severely in order to deter further
Behavior so that's the first and most
important part of the calculation
miscalculation there are a lot of other
dimensions so can we pause on that
really quick
so this is kind of idea of it's okay to
crack a few eggs to make an omelette
which is a more generous description of
what you're saying
that you don't incorporate into the
calculation the amount of human
suffering that the decisions cause but
instead you look at sort of
the success based on some kind of
measure for you personally and for the
nation
in not in terms of in the humanitarian
sense but in some kind of economic sense
and the power geopolitical power sense
yeah you're not sentimental X
you say to yourself
the cause of Russian greatness
is greater than any individual life
Russia being in the first rank of the
great Powers Russia realizing its
mission
to be
a special country with a special mission
in the world a civilization unto itself
the first rank of the great Powers maybe
even the greatest power that's worth the
price that we have to pay especially in
other people's lives right we have a lot
of literature on the Putin regime which
talks about the kleptocracy
the place is a kleptocracy and it is a
kleptocracy
we all can see that
and anybody in London live in the High
Life servicing this kleptocracy can
testify that it's a kleptocracy and not
only in London of course right here in
the United States in New York
but you know it's not only a kleptocracy
Lex
that was the problem of the Russian
studies literature
it wasn't just about stealing looting
the state it was about Russian greatness
you see those rituals in the Kremlin
right in the grand Kremlin Palace in the
St George's Hall
some of the greatest Interiors in the
world and you see award ceremonies and
you see marking holidays and all of
these looters of the state have their
uniforms on with their medals and
someone's given a speech or singing a
ballad and their eyes are moist
their eyes are moist because they're
thieves and looters no Lex because they
believe in Russian greatness
they have a deep and fundamental
passionate commitment to the greatness
of Russia which in unsentimental fashion
they're all sentimental to the max
that's why they're their their eyes are
moistening but they imagine
unsentimentally that any sacrifice is
okay a sacrifice of other people's lives
a sacrifice of their conscripts in the
military a sacrifice of Ukrainian women
and children and elderly that's a small
price to pay for those moist eyes about
Russian greatness and Russia's position
in the world well that human thing that
sentimentality is a thing didn't get us
in trouble in the United States as well
and lead us to Wars the illegal Wars and
so on but the United States as
repercussions
for breaking the law you're going to pay
for legal wars in the end you're saying
that in authoritarian regimes this
sentimentality can really get out of
hand and you can by charismatic leaders
they can take that to manipulate the
populace to make uh to that in in the
span of History led to atrocities and uh
in today's world lead to humanitarian
crises it's not just the kleptocracy
it's a belief system it's passion it's
conviction it's it's it's you can call
them Illusions you can call them
fantasies whatever you want to call them
they're real they're real for those
people and so yes they're looting that
very state that they're trying to make
one of the great powers in the world and
they resent
the fact that the West doesn't
acknowledge them as one of those great
powers and they resent that the West is
more powerful people talk about how
Putin doesn't understand
the world and that it gets really bad
information Lex if you're sitting there
in that Kremlin
and you're trying to conduct business in
the world and you're getting reports
from your finance minister or your
Central Bank governor
your whole economy everything that
matters somehow all your trade is
denominated in dollars in euros
do you have any Illusions about who
controls the International Financial
system I don't think so Lex
you looking over your industrial plan
for the next year
and you're looking over how many tanks
you're gonna get and how many cruise
missiles you're going to get and how
many submarines you're going to get and
and fill in the blank and you know what
it says right there in the paperwork
where the component parts come from
where the software comes from comes from
the West Lex
your whole military-industrial complex
is dependent on high-end Western
technology
and then and let's and let's say you're
in Beijing not just in Moscow and you go
to a meeting in your own neighborhood
you're the leader of China you go to a
meeting with other Asian leaders
do they all speak in Chinese with you
no Lex they don't speak Chinese
you go to an international meeting as
the leader of China and guess what
language is the main language of
intercourse
yes the same one you and I are speaking
right now
and so you live in that world you live
in the western world and it's very hard
to have Illusions about what world you
live in when you're under that PR you
need those Western Banks you need that
foreign currency right you need that
high-end Western technology that
technology transfer you're speaking or
you're forced to speak or your minions
are forced to speak at International
gatherings in English and and I could go
on all the indicators that you live in
and so Putin lives in that world he's no
fool
well to push back isn't it possible that
as you said the minions operate in that
world but can't you if you're the leader
of Russia or the leader of China or the
leader of these different nations
um
still put up walls where actually when
you think in the privacy of your own
mind you exist not in the international
world but in a world where there's this
great Russian Empire or this great
Chinese Empire yes and then you forget
that there's English you forget that
there's technology in iPhones you forget
that there's all this uh us keeps
popping up on all different paperwork
that just becomes the blurry details
that dissipate because what matters is
the greatness of this dream Empire that
I have in my mind as a dictator
I would put it this way Lex
after you absorb all of that
from your minions and and it impresses
upon your Consciousness where you live
you live in a western-dominated world
that the multipolar world doesn't exist
your goal is to make that multipolar
world exist your goal is to bring down
the West
your goal is for the West to weaken your
goal is a currency other than the dollar
in the euro your goal is is an
International Financial system that you
dominate your goal is technological
self-sufficiency made in China 2035
right your goal is a world that you
dominate not that the West dominates and
you're going to do everything you can to
try to attain that world
which is a russian-centric world or a
chinese-centric world or what we could
call a eurasian-centric world
and it's not going to be easy Lex just
for the reasons that where we enumerated
before
but maybe you're going to get a helping
hand maybe the West is going to transfer
their best technology to you they're
going to sell you their best stuff
and then you're gonna absorb it and
maybe copy it and reverse engineer it
and and if they won't sell it to you
maybe you'll just have to steal it
maybe the West is going to allow you to
bank even though you violate many laws
that would prohibit the west from
extending those banking services to you
maybe the West is going to buy your
energy and your Palladium and your
titanium and your rare metals like
lithium because you're willing to have
your poor people mind that stuff and die
of disease at an early age but Western
governments they don't want to do that
right they don't want to do that dirty
mining of those very important rare
Earths but you're willing to do that
because it's just people whose lives you
don't care about is an autocratic regime
right so that's the world you live in
where you're trying to get to this other
world
you're at the center of the other world
you dominate the other world but the
only way to get their legs is the West
has to weaken divide itself maybe even
collapse and so you're encouraging to
the extent possible
Western divisions you know Western
disunity a western lack of resolve
uh Western mistakes and Western invasion
of the wrong country and and Western
destruction of its credibility through
International Financial crises and
one could go on so the if the West
weakens itself through its mistakes and
its own corruption you're going to
survive and maybe even come out into
that world
where you're the center and so Russia's
entire Grand strategy just like China's
Grand strategy Iran it's hard to say
they have a grand strategy because
they're so
so profoundly weak
but Russia's Grand strategy is we're a
mess
we don't invest in our human capital our
human capital flees or we actually drive
it out it goes to MIT
like you did or it goes to fill in the
blank right we can't invest in our
people our health care is terrible our
education system is in Decline we don't
build infrastructure legs
we don't improve our governance we don't
invest in those attributes of modern
power that make the West powerful
we can't because when we try the money
is stolen
we try these grandiose projects of
national projects they're called we're
going to invest in higher ed we're going
to invest in high tech we're going to
build our own Silicon Valley known as
gulcavo we're going to do all those
things and what happens
they can't even build an airport without
the money disappearing the Sochi Olympic
selects it costs them officially cost
them 50 billion dollars you look around
at the infrastructure that endured from
that 50 billion dollar expense and
you're thinking you know that's like the
Second Avenue subway you get almost
nothing for your money
and so yeah it's corruption legs but
it's also because they don't want to do
that
they don't want to invest in their
people
they couldn't do it if they wanted to
and when they try it doesn't work but
why invest in your own people
invest in your Hardware your military
hardware
right invest in your cyber
capabilities invest in all your
spoilation techniques and your hard
power
and invest in
further corrupting and further weakening
and further dividing the West because as
I said if the West is weak divided
lacking resolve you don't invest in your
people you don't build infrastructure
you don't improve your governance but
you'll muddle through
that's Russian Grand strategy so invest
in the hard power
weaken the West those combined together
means you're going to be so incentivized
to escalate any military aggressive
conflicts
that are around you or create new ones
or if you can get away with murder but
what happens Lex if it's a Harry
truman-like response
what happens if somebody says you know
we're going to stand up to this
we're not going to allow this to happen
we're not going to launder your money
anymore
we're not going to be dependent on you
for energy in the long term we're going
to make a transition
we're going to punish you for that kind
of behavior instead and and the West is
now switched to that only because
of
the
courage and Ingenuity of the Ukrainian
people the Ukrainian resistance
to Russian aggression
was one of the greatest gifts the West
has ever received the sacrifices that
the ukrainians are making
right now as we speak
meaning they're fighting a war
by themselves against the major military
power their neighbor Russia
nobody's fighting it with them yes we
are giving them weapons so they can
conduct self-defense which by the way is
legal under international law
unlike the Russian invasion which is
illegal under international law
Western Supply of weapons including
heavy weapons including offensive
weapons to Ukraine for its self-defense
in The Invasion by Russia is actually
legal under and so
thank God the ukrainians
surprised everybody
they surprised me they surprised Putin
in the Kremlin they surprised the bide
Administration they surprised the
European Union not with the fact that
they would resist
we knew that
we had the orange revolution in 2004 we
had maidan in 2013-14 where they rose up
against a domestic tyrant
and they were willing to die on behalf
of their country then let alone against
the foreign Tyrant invading their
country right so we knew they would
resist we didn't know just how
successful certainly I didn't know they
would be on the battlefield it's been
breathtaking to watch that sacrifice
that gift enabled the West to ReDiscover
itself to ReDiscover its power to revive
itself to say the hell with this energy
dependence in the long term the hell
with this money laundering and
reputation laundering the hell with this
running back and forth to Moscow to try
to see what Putin needs in order for him
to feel respected what appeasement he
needs right so so we'll see if it
endures
but this shift comes from the ukrainians
and so it's no longer getting away with
murder Lex and we thank the ukrainians
for that the people and the leadership
and uh
the the separate factions that make up
Ukraine uniting the it's the unification
the uniting against the common enemy as
standing up before anyone knew that they
would be backed by all of these other
nations by this money and all this kind
of stuff standing there especially with
the president zielinski where it makes a
total sense to flee he stood his ground
and let's take that point that you just
raised which is a deep and fundamental
point and I thank you for that
do you guys hear that though I think
that was a compliment there we go let's
go flex so let's hear unification I'm
sitting here in front of you thank you
it's an honor and it's a mutual honor
so um Ukraine before the war is run by a
TV production company
right you're one guy running this
fantastic incredible podcast there's 20
guys or so running a country the size of
Ukraine yeah and and one's a producer
and one's like a makeup person and one's
a video editor and they're fantastically
talented people
if your country is a TV production so
before the war zolenski had what 25
approval rating and he couldn't get much
done and it wasn't working he got
elected with 73 percent as you know and
then he was down to 20 that's a pretty
big drop
and so you're thinking maybe having a
major large size 40 million plus
population European country run by a TV
production company is not the best
choice
and then what do we see we see President
zielinski decides
to risk his life on behalf of his
country Ukraine he decides to stay in
the capital
he's not going to flee he they're going
to stay and fight and he could be killed
he can die it's a decision where he put
his life on the line
obviously
he's Jewish descent
Russian speaking
childhood and upbringing
russian-speaking Jewish descent puts his
life on the line for the country of
Ukraine
it's a pretty big message don't you
think
and it's crucial
and it turns out not only that Lex
but they're good at TV they're good at
information war and in a war yeah it's a
TV production company and a TV
personality those that's exactly what
you want running a country
because they're crushing in the
information war and he's spectacular
European Parliament U.S Congress Israeli
Parliament there's no room on Zoom let
alone in person that he can't win over
he's just so effective you know this is
the first time reality TV
has been about reality instead of fake
reality TV is just this completely fake
nonsense but zielinsky this is real
reality TV and and he means it and and
the nation is behind him and and they're
just as courageous and just as ingenious
in many ways and it's spectacular
and so yeah
who saw that coming I didn't see that
coming Lex in fact the Biden we talk
about Putin's miscalculation the bid
Administration as you alluded to offered
him an exit from the country they didn't
say you know you want to stand and fight
we'll back you they said we'll get you
out you want to come now and famously
you know that quote right what he said
about how he doesn't need a ride
remember that yeah moment the Bible
Administration was poised to do another
Afghanistan moment that ignominious exit
from Afghanistan was almost what
happened in Ukraine when by the
administration offered him that ride out
of there and fortunately he declined and
helped rally and the people from below
also rallied to stop the Invader without
the presidency and without the
government in Ukraine saving the Biden
Administration and and the European
leaders who latched on fortunately they
had the presence of mine to latch on to
this gift this this bravery and
ingeniousness of of silensky and the
rest of the ukrainians and flipped and
decided to support Ukraine's resistance
you know first with 5 000 helmets only
as the Germans initially promised and
now with really heavy weapons
and so that's something that wasn't
foreseen I certainly didn't foresee that
I foresaw the Ukrainian Society being
courageous and resisting but I didn't
foresee a television production company
being exactly what you want to run a
country in a war a president's zelenski
willing to sacrifice lay down his life
and rallying others in the country to do
that and then the country being so
effective not just at a courage but at
Battlefield resistance to the Russian
invasion so I stand corrected by the
ukrainians and I'm ecstatic that I
didn't that I was wrong that I was
proven wrong and like I said there's
clear factions of the West and the east
of Ukraine and here's a person that like
you said was in the high 20s low 30s
percentage approval in the country
before the war and now was able to use
in the 90s in the 90s he's in the 90
approval rating I mean I I think they
stopped doing
the uh
the polling once he hit 91 or whatever
it was in the previous poll I think they
all understood that for now they didn't
need any more polling
that it's pretty clear the nation so 25
to 90 something percent
and and just like the 25 was deserved
the 90-something percent is also
deserved fully deserved and the question
is how that all stabilizes it feels
like this set of events I may be paying
attention to Twitter too much
which is a concern uh of mine whether
the change I see is just surface level
or deep level but it seems like we're in
a new world it's something dramatic has
shifted
that
um this power that's rooted I mean in
your study it
uh of the 20th century it's so deeply
rooted in history there's this power
center of the world is now going to it
has been shaken by this event and how
that changes the world is is unclear uh
it's unclear what lesson China learned
from watching this what lesson India
learns from watching this both Nations
as far as you can get polls about
Chinese population but both nations are
largely in support of Putin
so Russia India and China are still
supporting of Putin quietly I would
maybe uh um elaborate a little bit on
that point Lex I think you're right the
the feeling that we're in an inflection
moment you know an inflection point
I think that's widespread and I think
it's widespread for good reason we might
be
but I also share your
um
let's say
modesty about where it's going
and how hard it is to predict where this
might go it's only an inflection point
if the trends continue
right if the trends indoor
there are plenty of non-inflation points
after 9 11 the whole world rallied
around the United States after it was
attacked
after the the bombing of the towers here
in New York City and the hitting of the
Pentagon
and and that didn't last
and it was not really an inflection
point was it
it felt like it might be but it wasn't
and so this is not a comparable moment
in in terms of what happened
but it has the feeling that it might be
a watershed
and maybe we'll squander it the way we
squandered the post 911
rallying around the United States
maybe we'll actually consolidate it and
it'll endure or maybe it'll endure
despite ourselves
and we can't tell and we can't know yet
and it depends in part on what we do and
what we don't do
but here's a few things that we
understand already
the idea that the West Was in Decline
and that the rest of the world had risen
and was more powerful and that we lived
in a multi-polar world that turns out to
be empirically false
it's not true
I mean it's just factually not true
there are no major important
multinational institutions organizations
that are run
on behalf of or led by a South African a
Nigerian
a person from India
even the Chinese
don't run these institutions they would
like to and they're trying
but they don't
and so whatever you pick the IMF the
World Bank
the Federal Reserve which is the most
powerful multinational institution which
is actually only a domestic institution
and doesn't have a legal mandate to act
multilaterally but does
it's got the most power of any
institution in the world
NATO
the bilateral alliances that the U.S has
up and down Asia
what organizations that have tremendous
leverage on the International System on
the international order are non-western
the U.N is the most encompassing
and of course we know that the five it
has five members of the security Council
with a veto
one of which is Russia one of which is
China and the others are the US
Britain and France not India
not South Africa
not Indonesia not all of these other
countries where the people live
right the bulk of the population of the
world
and where the population is growing like
on the African continent
so it's not a multi-polar world we
talked already about the International
Financial system
that's the Western not multi-polar we
talked about the U.S military and NATO
where we could talk about the Japanese
military which is just very formidable
enormous number of platforms
even the Australian military we could
talk about Lex right
and so it's a western-dominated world
and the West remember is not a
geographic concept
it is an Institutional and values
Club
the Japanese are not European but
they're Western
just like Russia is European but not
Western
because European is a cultural category
and Western is an Institutional category
where you have rule of law and
separation of powers and free and open
public sphere and dynamic open market
economy
okay
and then we have another thing which is
pretty clear
the West is powerfully resented
powerfully envied and admired
simultaneously
PJ O'Rourke the comedian who died this
year
fantastic it was a big loss for the
culture
he said there were two things that are
always characteristic of any American
Embassy abroad
one is a political protest outside
and the other is the longest line you've
ever seen for visas
and those things are true simultaneously
and that's the world we live in meaning
that non-western countries
envy and admire the west but they also
resent the power of the West
Western hypocrisy right the West invades
countries when it wants but when others
do that it's illegal
right the West
arrests you for
money laundering but it's Western money
laundering that is where you go when you
need to launder money right so they see
the hypocrisy they see the excessive
power
that the West has and they resent it
and they say you who elected you to run
the world
we have a billion plus people or we have
a 200 plus million people and we don't
have a say
you're the self-appointed Guardians of
our world who did that and so it's
incumbent on the west not only to
remember
the power that it has
but also to exercise that power legally
and with restraint
and also to think about how we can
expand institutions to be more
encompassing
so that other parts of the world are not
on the outside
being dictated to
but instead are on the inside too often
right
Western power
is not consultative
in a decision-making fashion it's
consultative after the fact
okay you know we got together in the EU
where we got together in NATO or we got
together at the Federal Reserve and
here's our decision and we're announcing
it today
and so your economy gets destroyed
because the Federal Reserve decides it
has to raise interest rates
or you now uh go into default you can't
pay your debt because Western Banks lent
you money
and now the West has changed interest
rates or or other considerations
uh and you're in big trouble now and so
this is something which we fail to
address
it's very hard to address it's very hard
to reform International institutions
it's very hard to share power
it's very hard to acknowledge that you
have too much power
and that maybe having too much power is
not good not only for the rest of the
world but for yourself
and so it's great to ReDiscover the west
and ReDiscover its values and ReDiscover
its Authority and credibility and Power
but it's that's not sufficient so we
know this now we know that the rest of
the world
is not necessarily jumping on the
western bandwagon
right to condemn Russia for its actions
because the West can
do things like sanction your Central
Bank take away your reserves deny you
technology it pretty much can do
whatever it wants and it can say that
it's legal and it can go through various
mechanisms and and it can freeze your
property and and you say to yourself
should anybody have that much power and
when do they come after me
now there's a caveat here
and the caveat legs is
they don't like the West having all of
that power and they didn't join in the
condemnation of Russia
but they also didn't join in Russia's
aggression
so Russia's domestic civilian
um
Aerospace aircraft industry right
civilian aircraft industry is in big
trouble now because of the export
controls on spare parts and software
Brazil is a major power in aircraft
manufacturing did they rush in and say
you know
Vladimir Putin we didn't condemn
necessarily your actions in Ukraine okay
that's one thing and how about we give
you all of our aircraft technology and
we help you rebuild
your domestic aircraft industry and you
can have the aviation that the Western
did that happen Lex didn't happen
and you can look at India and you can
look at China and you can look at South
Africa and you can look at what they've
done in Practical terms
yes they haven't always joined in a
full-throated condemnation maybe they've
been neutral or maybe they've been
playing both sides of the fence like
turkey for example
but are they rushing in
to join Russia
to join Russia's aggression to supply
and there and the answer is no and the
answer is no for two reasons one they
actually don't want to be party to that
and two they understand that Western
power and and they don't want to be on
the receiving end
by crossing the west and then getting
caught up in a sanctions regime were
worse